- A cell phone producer distributes boxes
of units to retail stores.
A unit is either a cell
phone or an accessory,
and each box can have up
to 24 units composed of
c cellphones and a accessories.
In addition, each box must have at least
as many cell phones as accessories.
At least as many
cellphones as accessories.
Which of the following
systems of inequalities
best models the situation described above?
So let's just think it through.
So each box can have up
to 24 units composed of
c cellphones and a accessories.
So that means that the c cellphones plus
the a accessories, it
can be up to 24 units.
So it has to be less than or equal to 24.
This is the number of cellphones,
this the the number of accessories,
you add them together,
it has to be up to 24.
And then they tell us, and then
they tell us right over here
each box must have at least
as many cellphones as accessories.
So the cellphones have to
be greater than or equal to
the accessories.
All right, those are the constraints.
So let's see which of
these choices match them.
So, this one say 24 is less
than or equal a plus c.
No, it should be the other way around.
It should be 24 should be greater
than or equal to a plus c.
This is saying that a plus
c needs to be 24 or above.
But they say each box
can have up to 24 units.
They can't have 25 units
or anything like this.
So this is saying the opposite thing
than what this is saying.
This is saying c plus a has to
be less than or equal to 24,
this is saying 24 has to
be less than or equal to
c plus a or a plus c, so we
can just rule that one out.
This one also has that same
24 is less than or equal to a plus c,
so we can just rule that one out.
This one over here, let's see,
a plus c is less than or equal to 24,
well that's exactly what
we have right over here,
they just swapped the a and the c.
A plus c is less than or equal
to 24, and then over here
they have a is less than or equal to c,
which is equivalent to what this is.
Saying c is greater than or
equal to a is the same thing
as saying that a is
less than or equal to c.
So this is the choice I'd go with.
This choice right over here
has this constraint right,
but then it says that
the number of cellphones,
the number of cellphones has to be
no more than the number of accessories.
Another way to think about it,
is at least as many
accessories as cellphones,
which is the opposite,
is not what this constraint is saying.
So we could rule that one out as well.